hey guys this is dennis the founder
thing here i'm david griffin resident
comic book and video game guru and this
is our review of the pilot episode of
agents of shield well marbled new show
comes to ABC yeah produced by Joss
Whedon ma'am yeah the guy who directed
Avengers and and in this first episode
he wrote it and directed it I think he
co-wrote it with his brother Jed Whedon
and his wife Marisa a shortness to it ya
know that team actually did stuff in
spark is but they also helped out with
the Joss Whedon's dollhouse and dr.
horrible's sing-along blog okay as well
so they're part of the wing family
Marissa always jokes that she's the
Asian Whedon right yeah um so you know
this is pilot episode a lot of really
high expectations the reaction has been
from like people that loved it the
people that hated it I know a lot of
people that are on different sides of
events and I say I liked it it wasn't
for me it wasn't great and then love it
but I enjoyed it and I liked it and I
think there's a lot of potential there I
was definitely solid there are some
flaws will talk about later but would
you think it's fun I mean it had that it
has a very Whedon like you know banter
and comedy and you know I get there some
holes and there's some stuff in there
like okay but I mean it's fun I like to
cast or like you know the two scientists
or whatever the Fitz and Simmons Simmons
I mean they're they're fun i mean it's
it's got that light feel it's kind of
night i mean i think the problems you
watch too much heavy stuff yet I we
watch Borg empire at homeland and
breaking bad yeah just everything so
like that's why like once upon a time I
like this like ABC's kind of light you
know it's got some fun and some family
type stuff to it it's good I mean I'm
definitely staying I think a lot of the
haters didn't thought it was too like
that it was too much of a comedy too
silly and whatnot and I kind of
understand that it did go a little far
in terms of like it wasn't you know
maybe as serious as I thought it was
going to be but
you know you have to understand the way
if I mean I know a lot of people watch
the show because his agents of shield
and the other vendors are below but a
lot of these people are not familiar
with Joss Whedon they just think
Avengers like the first movie ever made
or so yeah but if you if you've ever
watched Joss Whedon shows other than it
Firefly which is great from the
beginning all his other shows start off
very slow right they actually don't get
going for a while Buffy I didn't get
into into the second season midway
through the second season angel I think
almost like third season or I didn't
start getting into it dollhouse I think
towards the end of the first season
sorry getting into it this is only the
first episode I'm pretty sure the show
is gonna edge towards more time because
because that's what he does if you've
ever watched buffy or angel it's all
silly in the beginning yeah and then it
gets it gets kind of dark I mean well he
got darker than I thought you know later
on so that's what I think is gonna
happen with agents of shield right i
mean i hope it does I hope it has a nice
balance that's why I was like about
Firefly Firefly had the comedy always
laughing every episode but also had the
drama it had a great balance of both but
you know I don't some of the stuff I
don't care about like the fact that
Coulson's alive I can't get mad at
because we are in a comic world and as
we know comic book characters do not
stay dead but the problem with that is
it's just like they're like oh he could
never know what happened on that island
or in feature ever he wasn't like I
don't care what how we think I really I
was like I really don't care how he came
back and they never so I mean it's just
it just seems kind of silly I think it's
actually gonna make integral part of the
show I I think it is I think people I
like the actor Alec are great oh yeah
he's great i'm glad he's back and he's
fine and I think that storyline is gonna
be weaved throughout the the show and
and I know fans want to know they want
to do we want a reasonable explanation
for it you know you see a clone did it
did you fear actually faked his death
maybe he went in a coma very vibrant
they use some new technology who knows
alright but there is definitely gonna be
some sort of mystery around what I'm
curious is because this part of Marvel
Universe I was I didn't expect to see is
there you
extremist in this episode which we just
saw this summer and what may now I on
three so I wonder now if I hope they
keep this routine going are they already
planned ahead for Thor so when we watch
we go see thor the dark world in
November are we going to see elements
may be in the second half of season 10
marla vent I mean I hope they kind of
cuz that universe are trying to keep it
tight well I hope they well having Joss
Whedon produce this series and having
his brother and his sister-in-law like
kind of the head when the head writers
for it I think that definitely there's
gonna be because he's he's in there with
all the movies like he's you know he's
overseeing Thor I mean uh Alan Taylor
mentioned that that that's also mean an
action for Nolan basically yeah like
Joss Whedon actually had a hand in some
of the writing rhymes are trying to
solve problems and how it fits within
the whole universe so yeah I you know I
won't be surprised to see a some of the
Thor elements you know play out or order
play out but like have some consequences
that affect visions of shield yeah no I
mean it's illegal be fun it'll be
entertaining WC i mean III like the lead
actor no the actors name or his name but
the characters yeah yeah the agent yeah
grant grant yeah i like him you know me
nah you know first of stargate universe
y'all you know come on she's good i
should be around a long time but yeah I
mean it's custom all good cameo Maria
Hill Cobie Smulders Richmond wants to
have a bigger role at some point so yeah
we done with time at your mother maybe
she can I mean how I mean Reds on the
last season's I don't know how much time
she has but hopefully she gets to peek
in once in a while so you know I'm
saying a lot of positive stuff and about
the potential and all stuff so now to
the negative things I didn't like I did
not care for the character of sky the
hacker girl oh she's hot you know but 11
I don't believe she's a hacker you know
at all and to all a girl is in she was
in the van yes yeah rising tide you know
this is rising tide hacker group feels a
great
one right you know yeah she hunts down
Mike Peterson who angel and Joss Whedon
fans know he played gun in that series
so Joss Whedon looks like he's bringing
people back he had a book from we love
doing that little Firefly goes in there
he a small small role I'm sure he'll be
back as well I don't know if gun is
gonna be back I mean mike peters right
um but yeah I didn't care for that
character you know I thought was a
little silly to ever as a hacker with
perfect hair living out of a van that's
agency know that lesson clean and pretty
you know and then on and of course they
set it up this this hate love hate
relationship between her and grand you
know is already starting you know that's
gonna turn you guys are really sure of
and he's like you're the most like says
all those stuff about her yeah you know
that's gonna turn into a relationship
later on so I think that you know kind
of turned me off to her character as
well and also just this inclusion into
shield single a bit easy to kind of let
her like see everything route like you
know there's always places of it suppose
she could ever from like a lot of people
for being secret a lot of people see
what's going on in exactly and they're
like oh just come on to here here check
out all this information coming in this
meeting we're gonna tell you all this
stuff alright and so that's why it maybe
she'll grow into a character that all
like in the future but as of right now I
think she's it's kind of silly and I
hope for budgetary reasons I know it's
may be difficult but I hope maybe every
now and then we get a cameo I don't
think it'd be too hard for Chris hands
with a show up on set for an hour just
put on the costume to show up you know
just a light and then leave or something
I hope I don't know if I mean that those
guys cost a lot of my so we'll see but I
hope me we see the guys when I don't why
I think what I think what will Morsi is
like clips welcome not clips but like
we'll see like the back of a Thor flying
away you know or like Iron Man you don't
need a robert downey jr. it you can
still just have the shooter where I
don't know if they're gonna take it off
is the other guy just know they're gonna
pay for the visual effects to do this
soon
but they might have that type of stuff
but I don't foresee them ever being you
know even guest stars you know that's
gonna be tough those guys schedules but
yeah it's uh that's good i think it'll
be fun you know if anything it'll be you
know just something to watch kind of a
little scape ism it's good yeah and i
think you know the first episode is not
where we're gonna judge my series i mean
like i said it it's in joss whedon's
pattern where yeah he starts off
light-hearted and it's kind of silly but
eventually he starts going down and you
know much darker road so i hope
hopefully that's where the show is going
alright guys so that's what we thought
of the pilot episode of agents of shield
let us know anything you post your
comments on the website or on our
youtube page that's a think hero pro
make sure you subscribe and we are also
on twitter you can chat with us there
and my name is a my screen name is actin
kara i'm at griffin de and we also have
a Facebook page that's a facebook.com
slash take care of fans
you